Dominique stroscan bonsoir avant d'en
venir au au dossier judiciaire peut-être
une ou deux questions personnelles
maintenant vous voyez un peu la fin du
tunnel en tout cas le début de la fin du
tunnel qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti
qu'est-ce que vous avez perdu ou laissé
de
vous-même c'est dur honnêtement c'est
dur je peux pas avoir l'air de me
plaindre beaucoup d'hommes ou de femmes
ont subi des épreuves de même nature
parfois beaucoup plus difficiles et mais
lorsquon on a le sentiment que on est
innocent qu'on a rien fait qu'on a fait
les choses comme il fallait les faire
euh on a l'impression que c'est un peu
long et qu'on se bat un peu contre un
mur avec le l'pression qu'onarrive pas à
faire valoir son bon droit qu'on vous
écoute pas finalement au bout du compte
je m'aperois que c'est pas le cas donc
j'ai envie de dire que vous n'êtes pas
blanchi dans toutes les affaires on va
pas parler de toutes les affaires laamnf
reste dossier on ne sait pas encore en
tout cas dans cette affaire précise le
le le dossier j'ai B d'espoir qui se
solde pendant l'été correctement c'est
ce qu'on m'a laissé entendre et puis ame
nef sera jugé en octobre je suis serein
là-dessus aussi mais sur cette affaire
là qui était quand même très très dure
parce que bon être accusé de corruption
de concussion c'est quand même
lourd bon le fait que les deux plus
hauts magistrats du du parquet le
procureur général auprès de la Cour
d'appel monsieur Nadal le procureur
général auprès de la Cour de cassation
monsieur Burgelin et le courage de dire
bah finalement on a regardé et il y a
rien arrêtons cette histoire d'abord ça
montre qu'ils ont effectivement du
courage et puis par ailleurs ça ça fait
chaud au cœur est-ce que si c'était à
refaire que referiez-vous de la même
façon mais surtout que ne referiez-vous
pas alors dans ce dossier précis je
crois que je crois que bon j'ai beaucoup
de défauts comme tout le monde mais j'en
ai un qui est d'avoir trop de tendance à
pas me concentrer sur les détails à
faire confiance aux gens à mépriser les
questions secondaires à m'intéresser à
ce qui est central dans une affaire et
puis on s'aperçoit que les questions
secondaires elles peuvent être très
importantes et que si on n pas réglé
exactement tous les détails bah
finalement ça peut vous rattraper à la
fin et ça a des conséquences faut
apprendre surtout dans les
responsabilités que j'ai j'ai pu exercer
mais alors vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas une victime vous êtes victime si je
vous comprends bien victime de vous-même
d'une forme d'insouciance je me présente
pas du tout comme une victime je crois
que j'ai été imprudent imprudent et que
bah justement c'est cher payé pour
apprendre mais enfin au moins que ça
serve à apprendre alors par exemple sur
l'imprudence est-ce qu'il était bien
nécessaire de recevoir maître Bellot qui
était quand même un ancien collaborateur
un moment où lui-même s'occupait du
dossier fiscal de de Monsieur lagarfel
est-ce que ce n'était pas un risque
inutil que vous ne reprendriez pas
auourdhui non je l'avais pas vu comme
çaatber voyez-vous d'abord j'ai reçu
beaucoup d'avocats avec leurs clients et
beaucoup de ces avocats je les connais
comme je connais les client vous savez
la la France c'est un pays qui est pas
avec des centaines de millions
d'habitants donc on quand on a déjà
exercé des responsabilités j'avais déjà
été ministre j'avais déjà eu
responsabilité politiquque on en a déjà
croisé beaucoup et donc si le ministre
des Finances chaque fois qu'il doit
recevoir un avocat par exemple avec son
client sur un sujet ou sur un autre qui
le concerne ou qui concerne son
entreprise devait dire ah mais vous je
vous ai déjà rencontré alors je veux pas
vous voir il pourrait pas exercer son
activité bon là où j'ai sans doute pas
été suffisamment prudent en effet c'est
que quand monsieur Bellot m'aattendu
cette cassette cette fameuse cassette en
me disant ça va vous intéresser euh ben
j'aurais pas dû la prendre j'aurais dû
tout de suite avoir le réflexe de dire
non non je veux pas voir de quoi il
s'agit ou de la remettre à la justice
j'aurais pas dû la prendre je pense que
c'était plus sûr car si je l'avais prise
et si je l'avais remis à la justice si
je l'avais regardé et à ce moment si je
l'avais remise à la justice ça aurait
fait un tel scandale politique que le
ministre des Finances remettent à la
justice une cassette qui comprenait
quelque chose qui concernait pas la rque
que ça aurait été ça se discute c'est en
doute un devoir en tout cas c'est la loi
que de remettre quelque chose lorsqu'on
a pris connaissance en plus de toute
façon je n'ai pas je n'ai pas fait mais
si ça avait été le cas est-ce que vous
avez fait refait dans votre tête
remonter le temps vous disant si j'étais
la minute d'avant j'ai remonté un peu le
temps mais vous savez ça sert pas à
grand-chose ce qui comptait pour moi
dans cette affaire principalement
c'était que le dossier de monsieur
lagarfel avait été traité par les
services des impôts ça faisait 20 ans
que ça duré cette histoire et moi
j'avais donné les instructions pour
qu'on trouve une solution mais la
solution a été proposée par le service
des des impôts tous les fonctionnaires
des impôts sont venus témoigner pour
dire ça a été le cas ça a été traité
correctement justement il y a un point
que je voudrais corriger c'est qu'il n
y'y a pas eu de cadeau fiscal comme je
l'entends parfois il y a eu simplement
le calcul juste des impôts que devait
monsieur lagarfel il y a une question
qui m'intrigue moi depuis le début
est-ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
d'avoir démissionner trop vite et est-ce
qu'au fond vous n'avez pas fait la
mauvaise stratégie non je sais que
beaucoup de mes amis ou de concitoyens
pensent cela ce n'est pas mon avis un
ministre est en charge de responsabilité
considérable notamment le ministre des
Finances lorsqu'il est accusé de quelque
chose il doit d'abord s'en laver ce que
je pensais c'est que ça durerait pas
longtemps et là on touche un grand
problème qui me concerne pas uniquement
qui est celui de la longueur des
procédures judiciaires je pensais quand
2 3 mois puisque moi je savais que ce
travail avait été fait donc je pensais
qu'en 2 3 mois l'affaire serait réglé et
je considérais que on fait partie d'une
équipe d'un gouvernement celui de Lionel
Jospin au vous a pas lâché un peu vite à
cette époque non non le Premier ministre
ne voulait pas que je démiss
et moi j'ai pensé que le gouvernement
être attaqué tous les jours par
l'opposition qu'à l'Assemblée tous les
jours il y aurait des questions des
critiques et que mon rôle était pas de
mettre Lionel Jospin et le gouvernement
en difficulté donc valit mieux que je me
retire je règle mes affaires une fois
qu'ell sera réglé on verrait bien ce que
j'avais pas anticiper c'est que ça
durera si longtemps Bernard Pivot sera à
votre place dans quelques instants notre
invité vous savez que ce soir c'est sa
dernière émission vous av envie de lui
dire un mot un commentaire l'admiration
formidable qu forme able homme de
télévision j'ai bon ma génération les
plus jeunes peut-être s'en souviennent
moins mais on t'appris presque à lire
avec pivot on t'apis ce que c'était
qu'un livre l'amour de la lecture puis
en plus extraordinaire présence à
télévision non je veux par votre
intermédiaire et quelques minutes avant
qu'il apparaisse juste le saluer merci
dominiic strusken d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en attendant Bernard Pivot
nous poursuivons cette édition avec au
chapitre judiciaire la décision du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
a épargné au doyen des juges
d'instruction de Nice Jean-Paul renard
la suspension temporaire le magistrat
était soupçonné d'avoir consulté le
fichier du casier judiciaire pour
informer sa loge maçonnique ENF cette
décision attendue de la Cour de
cassation qui considère que le fetus
n'est pas une personne à ce titre il ne
peut y avoir domicide involontaire
décision suivante à un accident provoqué
par un chaufard au cours duquel une
automobiliste en de 6 mois avait fait
une fausse couche